Speaker 1: All right, let's look at a couple
of other things, this is one of the wackiest,
wackiest video clips I have seen
in my entire time doing this show.
This is a woman we've spoken about before.
This is end times preacher Sharon Gilbert.
Now, Sharon Gilbert claims that an alien
imitated her husband, tried to have sex
with her. She figured out the alien was actually
Zeus seas, and somehow Jesus was a factor as well.
And the alien was a reptile with gargoyles.
Now I'm going to play the clip for you.
We're not laughing at mental illness. We're not
joking about mental illness, it's not funny.
My serious question is, isn't this very
serious mental illness where you would say,
are you being medicated? Are you under the care
of a psychiatrist? Would there be if this was
not called Christianity, but just non-religious
delusions and it was your cousin doing this?
Wouldn't you say you should check yourself into
an E.R., maybe a psych hold? It's not a joke.
Why do they get out of just saying
being told you're sick because it's
under the guise of religion? Listen to this
Speaker 5: after Derek and I got married
one night. This other Derek. Appears in our
bit. The real Derrick is lying down next to me.
Other Derek sits right up out of it. It
startled me. I knew that was not Derek.
And so I ask this critter.
Speaker 1: Who are you,
right?
Speaker 5: Because
he clearly wanted to have sexual relations?
Speaker 1: What happened to I have a headache
and you just leave it at that, you
know, you're not the real Derek.
You're an alien. I mean, it's. Or did this guy get
caught masturbating by her and pretended to be an
alien? I can't tell what the real story is here.
Speaker 5: And I said he said, Come on, I'm your
husband, I said, Who are you? And he had the
nerve to claim to be. They are housewares. Xerxes,
Xerxes, well, other Derik seriously wanted to
invite me to use my free will. To do something
that was going to pull me away from
Speaker 1: God, by the way, notice that
they are selling at the bottom of the screen, the
Great Delusion DVD bundle, it seems to be just
I wonder if it's just delusions like this one.
Speaker 5: So this last time. I knew.
He was really desperate. Yeah. And
I asked him again, who are you told
me the same answer and I said he was really
Speaker 1: desperate by now because the first
time she said, You're not really Derek,
Speaker 5: not going with you. This was
an internal dialog. Finally, I said,
I've had enough. Yeah, in my mind.
I reached up. I grabbed his
face and I said, you are a liar.
And Jesus is real, and I pulled that face
off right and beneath it was a reptile hoof,
and he had little creatures with him this time. He
brought these little halfling creatures and they
looked like, I don't know, gargoyles.
Speaker 1: They're guy's nodding by.
There's two guys sitting next to
her, and if you're not watching,
they're nodding to everything she's saying
Speaker 5: very reptilian as well. So beneath that
face of Derek was a reptilian serpentine creature,
probably similar to what was visiting the Anasazi.
Speaker 1: You know, I continue to believe,
Hey, honey, I'm really tired. Tonight is probably
still more sensible. But again, if if this is
real and we're joking around about it, if this is
really her belief. Is this not a very, very sick
individual, and you have to remember that there
is a way you know it, they've created a layer of
protection for themselves where they go. It's my
religious belief and many people, when they hear
that, they go, Oh, OK, let me just. And where is
the line angels demons? Zeus reptile was actually
in the body of my husband trying to have sex with
me. What where is the line where we say, Lady,
this is bonkers. We got to have you evaluated?
You tell me. You tell me where that line is.